- [Interviewer] All right, Alanna
- [Alanna] Uh huh.
- [Interviewer] Alanna,
where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Alanna] Camarillo.
- [Interviewer] So you're an LA girl?
- [Alanna] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
Did you have both parents growing up?
- Well, I was adopted.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah, but I came here
when I was an infant,
so, you know, it's all the same,
but my parents are Caucasian, you know,
upper class, teachers.
- [Interviewer] Good childhood?
- Yeah, you know, sheltered.
Real sheltered.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah, beyond sheltered,
but yeah.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- You know what, I
really, I could actually
you know what, my parents didn't
really let me do too much,
so I was kind of rebellious, you know,
where I'd try to have fun
but not, you know, but on the down low.
But then my dad, he passed
away when I was in high school
so it was just my mom
and my brother and I,
so I kind of, you know, decided to,
I actually was pretty
smart in high school,
so I ended up going to junior college
while I was in high school,
so I could slip away,
break away from the house
since I was never able
to go anywhere usually.
But it was okay, you know.
- [Interviewer] Did you got to college?
- Yeah, I did.
I did go to college.
But I was graduated before I was 20.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah, so, yeah.
But then I got caught up
with the wrong people.
- [Interviewer] Is that
what got you to this career?
- Yeah pretty much.
Started dating a guy that my
mom thought was in his 20s
when he was in his 40s.
Yeah, and that's where it all began.
- [Interviewer] And were there
- It was all bad.
- [Interviewer] things like drugs and?
- Drugs, sex parties, you name it.
Oh yeah, he was a freak.
That's about where everything
turned for me I guess.
- [Interviewer] At what
point did you start working
as an exotic dancer or stripper, whatever?
- Um, probably when I
was about 23, 22, 23.
- [Interviewer] So rather
than pursuing a career
that was,
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] that you studied
in school, you chose this?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I'll never forget,
I was at a friend's house
and I had no idea.
I had never even smelled
what marijuana was.
I did not even know
what weed smelled like.
And then, like, we had found a baggie,
I can talk about this right?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, of course.
- I found a baggie of like white stuff,
and I was like, "What is this?"
and then my boyfriend at
the time, he came over,
and he was like, "Oh, Let
me tell you what that is.
"Cocaine."
And it was all, my life
change at that point, yeah.
But we would go to these parties,
and yeah he was a freak.
Freak.
And then I just figured out
that was kind of fun for me,
you know so.
Like I'd been missing
it all my whole life.
So I'm like, uh, okay.
- [Interviewer] So your
childhood was kind of
- It was sheltered.
- [Interviewer] sheltered.
- It was so sheltered, it was like.
- [Interviewer] You became a
wild kid when you were free.
- Oh my God, I was a freak.
Yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have kids of your own?
- Uh uh.
- [Interviewer] Never married?
- Uh huh. Nope.
- [Interviewer] So you work
at some of the strip clubs
in the Valley or in LA?
- I used to, like a couple of em.
But now it's just private parties
cause I'm older now, you know.
I need to make more money and--
- [Interviewer] And you make
more money being a private?
- Yeah, totally, totally.
Because there's, you know,
and, I mean, things go beyond
just the dance, you know what I mean.
So, which whatever, that's fine.
- [Interviewer] Understood.
- You know, I'm unattached so I can do
whatever I wanna do.
- [Interviewer] But you'll
do like bachelor parties
and things like that
- Yeah. Hell yeah.
- [Interviewer] and the
guys are having a good time
- Uh huh
- [Interviewer] And you get
to make some extra money.
- Yeah, a lot of extra money.
- That's cool.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I've met a lot of people that you know
the networking thing is really good.
- [Interviewer] It's
probably a better lifestyle
than working til all hours
at a strip club, right?
- Yeah, totally.
Yeah, and even people in the strip clubs,
they don't really pay you that
much, you know what I mean?
So, yeah, it's a lot better.
You just get your, you
make your deal beforehand,
more business in that sense,
if that makes sense.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Do you still use any drugs?
- I do.
- [Interviewer] What's your drug today?
- Uh, G.
- [Interviewer] What is G?
- GHB.
It's the date rape drug.
- [Interviewer] Is that right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you take it,
and what does it do for you?
- It makes you just not
care about anything.
It makes any inhibitions you have, gone.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
So you'll take it,
and you'll stay at home when you do this,
or you'll go out?
- I'll go out, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And has
it gotten you in trouble?
- You're not supposed
to be driving on it and stuff like that,
but I drive.
- [Interviewer] Has it
gotten you in trouble?
- Not in trouble.
No I totally like know my limits.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- So that's good.
But some people when they take it,
it's all bad,
but thank God it's not bad for me.
- [Interviewer] So it's kinda
like drinking alcohol where?
- Yeah, without a hangover.
- [Interviewer] It
removes your inhibitions.
- Short term, it's like three four hours,
and you're good.
- [Interviewer] And you take it as a pill?
- It's a liquid.
It looks like water.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Just like a little bottle cap full.
It's not much.
- [Interviewer] Interesting.
- Yeah, tastes like salty balls.
(laughing)
But, yeah, it's good.
- [Interviewer] And so do you,
looking back at your life,
do you ever wish you had maybe,
what regrets might you have?
- [Alanna] (exhaling) You
know what, I hate to say it,
but like I really, I don't really,
I don't know.
I don't like to look at my
life and look for any regrets.
You know what I mean, like
that's like my biggest fear
to like be on my deathbed and go,
"Oh my God, I regret this.
"I feel bad about this."
You know what I mean.
I don't feel bad about it, at all.
I used to go up to my, I mean,
I used to.
I worked at the mall at one point,
okay, before I got, you know,
really, freaky, (laughing)
and I remember making friends there,
and since I wasn't like one
to like have slumber parties
and all that stuff, you
know, when I was growing up,
so I, you know, made
new friends at the mall,
and I remember I used to
screw all their boyfriends.
So maybe that's what I regret,
because, you know, they don't
really look good on that,
then you kinda lose your friends.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Alanna] That's kinda
lame, but other than that,
at the time I didn't care.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Do your parents know you're doing this?
- [Alanna] No.
- [Interviewer] They still don't know?
- [Interviewer] You've been
doing it all these years,
what do you tell them you're doing?
- [Alanna] Food delivery.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah.
They may know now, no.
- [Interviewer] No.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] There's a lot
of videos on YouTube to find.
- I mean, honestly as long
as I don't ask em for help,
then they think everything's fine.
They're kinda like that.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- You know what I mean.
So, it kinda works out in my favor.
But if I ask them for help,
they'll look more into my life.
Do you know what I mean, so?
- [Interviewer] I'm sure
you've got some crazy stories
of working as a stripper
all those years, right?
- Yeah, lots.
There has been some freaks.
And I started dating this one guy
who was a girl trapped in a man's body.
So that was kind of interesting.
Okay, but he was a lesbian
trapped in a man's body.
(laughing)
I know it sounds weird, but you know.
And he had nicer legs than me,
and he had long black hair.
But he introduced me to a
lot of people, biker people.
He was a biker, which was interesting.
But he was a guy in front of them,
but then when he'd go up
to these other parties,
it was interesting,
but we used to go, and like, you know.
He would like, you know,
me and a couple of girls
would go, like you know,
they would have their parties and stuff,
and it was good, it was fun.
It would be like,
it just turned out to be
more, you know, sexual.
Do you know what I mean?
So, yeah.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What advice
would you give a young girl
who's considering this as a career?
- (sighs) You know, just, you know,
You know, I don't know.
I just feel like I could
be easily persuaded.
Do you know what I mean, like?
It's kinda weird because,
like, you're out there,
everything's out in the open.
It's like you should
have a fear of rejection.
Do you know what I mean?
So you kinda go along with the program.
I don't know, I just feel like, just keep,
stand up for yourself when
you need to, you know,
but do what you want to do.
You know, it's your only life you have.
- [Interviewer] Do you
feel like who you are today
is more who Alanna is
than maybe who you were
with your parents.
- Oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] This is
more who you really are?
- Yeah, totally.
- [Interviewer] And you're Asian, right?
You're?
- Korean.
- [Interviewer] Korean.
Do you think there are
more Koreans, Asians,
that might be the wilder
and freer as you are,
- Oh yeah. Totally.
- [Interviewer] and they're very repressed
- Oh yeah
- [Interviewer] Because of the culture?
- Big time.
- [Interviewer] And the parents?
- Yeah, because I had some friends
that were like Korean even in high school,
because I would like
sneak out of my house.
I literally got to learn how
to put my car in neutral.
We had a driveway that went down,
put my car in neutral in
the middle of the night,
coast down, parents never knew
when I came home, you know.
But, they would be like,
"What'd you do last night?"
And I'm like, "Oh, I went
out with duh-duh-duh-duh."
But they would be like,
it would be all bad,
if they had wanted to do that.
Yeah, I know they were totally repressed
and like, I mean, but I
know the wild was in them.
But yeah, I don't know, I just think
in the end it makes you
unhappy if you can't do
what you want to do and
be who you want to be.
- [Interviewer] Absolutely.
- You know, I mean, I
can't say I'm unhappy
with myself or anybody else.
Like, things are good.
So I can't complain.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Uh huh.
- [Interviewer] All right, Alanna.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
And good luck.
- Thanks.
- [Interviewer] With
whatever you end up doing
- Thanks.
- [Interviewer] From here.
Okay, thank you.